amy my wife who you guys know i think
said to conan and tomino you're going on
tour rodman should film this so it all
kind of came together and you're right
so it happened very very fast
i couldn't wait for
financing or anything it was all
happening so like the meetings
happened like like you said like the
following week right after
the last tonight show right so i knew i
had to capture that right away so i got
you know i just got got equipment and uh
just started shooting oh and the other
thing was obviously i i pitched my take
to conan and conan had seen the upper
crest documentary let them eat rock and
he really liked that a lot
and i i said to him you know i wanted to
to capture this and and pitched him this
idea that it was kind of this this weird
inversion and i said
you know i i don't want it to seem like
a conan o'brien product i didn't want it
i just wanted to i didn't have an agenda
right i was just i thought it was
interesting that he was going on tour
i wasn't you know um michael moore who i
love and he's been very very kind to me
but you know he makes documentaries to
prove a point right you know to further
some agenda there's a thesis there when
there's a thesis i i had no thesis i
just wanted to capture what happened or
what was going to happen
and
i i said to conan
good whatever's going to happen good bad
ugly i just i just want to capture it
and
you got to know if this smells like
something that came that was approved by
your publicity department i don't have
anything to do with that
for some crazy reason he said okay
[Laughter]
to this day i still don't know why you
can ask him why he said okay but he said
okay so i just started filming
everything right away after a week he
was going through camera withdrawal
it had been 10 days
start shooting start shooting shoot this
conversation and i think because rodman
because you guys were so close you had
just access to everything i mean you
were he he trusted right you coming in
and filming processes that i don't think
he's ever filmed right sweeney you would
know better than me but i don't think
he's ever had anybody film the writer's
room before uh no not really yeah that
is a big factor the fact that you guys
were already pals because
yes a lot of times like if a show
you know like entertainment tonight was
visiting the show and those cameras were
shooting behind the scenes oh it would
all be fake i'm sure
like the von trapp children lining up
yeah
everyone's on best behavior and and kind
of paranoid well how did i mean here's i
have questions for you guys how do you
think sweeney the the fact that i was
there with the camera
affect the writer's room did it change
it in any way or oh good question after
a while i was like oh you know what i'm
gonna i'm gonna duck out just because
i get nervous with cameras around
personally but everyone's different like
sona i don't think cameras bother you at
all well i just never thought that i
would be like in it because i thought it
was just always on conan so i was i mean
i was eating so much throughout that
documentary there's so many times when
i'm just unattractively shoving
something into my mouth because i'm like
why why is the camera on me oh that's
funny that could be a whole nother
documentary it could
it was just so many moments where i was
and all yeah and you're right i mean i
just i think i just forgot that the
camera was there for a second but
because it was there so often well i
mean i don't think you forgot i don't
think i mean the first time i met you i
had the camera on
and shooting and it was and
you're remarkable because you were just
so relaxed and at ease and it was it was
as if there was no camera i mean you are
so authentic yes
no i i really do think there is
something to i think that i just was
like this was a conan documentary i'm i
might be in the background of a few
shots but i never actually thought that
i would be i was i think that was the i
mean i i really didn't anticipate being
a part of the documentary and i think
that i was
surprised maybe if i knew that i would
have acted a little differently but i
don't i have no idea i don't know you
became the breakout star yeah
show early cuts
people loved you so much and i i think
your chemistry with conan on on camera
uh was that the first time was it the
first time that the two of you appeared
together on camera because it was and i
think like like sweeney and jesse i
think you you're very kind to me in the
editing process i i'm i think that there
was no i wasn't you guys really are no
you are you guys are very kind and i
think that there's i think people really
respond to my relationship with conan
and you really captured that and i was
only working for him for like a year at
that point so it was just a very odd
sort of dynamic i think i don't know i
mean it but it was i always tell people
it was the best
summer camp i ever went to and that
documentary is like watching a video of
my favorite summer camp
yeah that's how i always described it